من سرمدا بشمال سوريا ينضم الينا احمد
يزجي عضو مجلس مجلس اداره الدفاع المدني
السوري
واستاذ احمد يعني اذا امكن التحدث عن
ارقام تقديريه او يعني عن عدد النساء
والاطفال الذي تم انقاذهم حتى الساعه
والذين ما زالوا مفقودين ايضا حد الساعه
للاسف الارقام اللي ممكن انا اتداول حاليا
هي ارقام متغيره خلال دقائق
فالرقم خلال هذه الدقيقه يشير الى 1640
سفير بالاضافه الى 2800 جريح تم توثيقهم
من قبل طرق الدفاع المدني الذي تعمل الى
حد هذه اللحظه على افراد العالقين من تحت
الانقاذ منذ حوادث تقريبا ساعه
اخرجنا طفل على قيد الحياه في منطقه
عزمارين
على امل ان يكون هناك ان يكون هناك عده
نادين
موجودين تحكم انفاض ويكونوا على قيد
الحياه نعمل على هذا الامل ونعيش على هذا
الامل رغم الامكانيات المتوفره بين يدينا
روما بروده الطقس شديد التي وصلت الان الى
0 وفي بعد منتصف الليل تصل الى مادون
الصفر نعمل على هذا الامل ان يكون هناك
نادين تحت الان
استاذ احمد بظل الامكانات التي يعني
الموجوده لديكم هناك بظ
ل بظل النقص على كافه المستويات هل بدات
تتضاءل الامال بوجود ناجين تحت الانقاض
كلما تقدم لنا ساعه كلما تضاءلت الامل في
اخراج العالقين من تحت الانقاض بالامس
ناشدنا جميع الدول ان يتم الاستعجال في
ارسال المعدات الخاصه في عمليات البحث
والانقاذ لكي نتمكن من اخراج اكبر عدد من
الناديين ولكن كلما تقدمت ساعه كلما
كان هناك
مفقودين اكثر فللاسف نقول للاسف ان تاخير
دخول هذه المساعدات التي تساعد على انتشال
العالقين والتي تساعد فرق الدفاع المدني
التي اعتمدت على امكانياتها واعتمدت على
الجهات المدنيه والمحليه
والفرق التطوعيه
نتامل كانت ستساعد اكثر ولكن تاخير دخولها
هكذا مساعدات
العمل في قروض
حديثك عن عن يعني عن ان الوقت اليوم
السباق مع الوقت اصبح حرج بعدما تاخرت
المساعدات ما تم يعني انتشاله بالساعات
الماضيه هل نتحدث عن جثث فقط ام ان هناك
بعض الاحياء الذين ما زلتم تستطيعون
انقاذهم لان طبعا هذا مؤشر على ساعات
المقبله
انا كما اسلفت سابقا انه خلال تقريبا
حوالي ساعه واخرجنا على قيد الحياه يعني
هناك امل ان يكون اشخاص على قيد الحياه
نعيش على هذا
المعدات كانت ستساعد كثيرا هذه المساعدات
كانت تساعد كثيرا في اخراج عدد اكبر من ال
ال
المدنيين الذين هم على قيد الحياه ولكن
كلما تاخرت ساعه كلما ازداد رقم الوفيات
ونقص عدد الاصابات للاسف نقولها للاسف
لاننا
كنا على امل ان تكون هذه المساعدات تكون
في اقرب وقت ممكن ولكنها كانت عباره عن
وعود ولكن هذه الوعود كانت
نتمنى ان كانت تترجم بسرعه قسوه الى الان
تبقى وعود الى الان يوجد العالقين تحت
الانقاب الى الان يوجد درجات حراره منخفضه
جدا يا عيسى اناس تحت هذه الانقاذ على امل
انقاذهم من قبل الفرق الدفاع المدني ولكن
للاسف نعمل بكل بكامل طاقات نواصل الليل
بالنهار نواصل الوقت كامل لعمليات الافراد
عايشين على امل متقاتلين جميعا
ما يفيد الفرق دفاع المدني دخول المساعدات
بعد
خمسه ايام
كمعدات استاذ احمد يعني الزملاء كانوا
يتحدثوا عن حوالي 30% من المباني المتضرره
او المباني التي دمرت بالكامل تم انتشال
من هم تحتها بالساعات الماضيه وتفتيشها
بحسب الدفاع المدني هل نتحدث عن اقل او
اكثر
ممكن تم توسيق
من كره الدفاع المدني حوالي 360 مبنى هدم
بشكل كامل بالاضافه لاكثر من 1100 مبنى
تهدم بشكل جزئي بالاضافه الى الاف المباني
التي
تعرضت للصدع ان قلت الاف فهذا رقم يعني
قليل المباني سابقا كما يعلم الجميع انها
كانت عرضه لقصف من قبل الطيران الروسي
والسوري على هذه المنطقه ما طاقم الوضع هو
هذا الزلزال الذي ادى الى انهيارات عديده
في المباني ما ايضا فاقمه في الوضع ايضا
هي الهزات الارتداديه التي رافقت هذا
الزلزال وثق الاقتران خلال
اليومين الماضيين الى حد هذه اللحظه
تهدمت ست مباني بشكل كامل من جراء الذات
الابتداديه
ايضا عملنا بالاضافه ما يؤخر ايضا في
اعمالنا هي تلك الهزات الارتزاديه التي
ممكن ان يكون المبنى المجاور للمبنى الذي
نعمل به يؤدي الى انهيار بشكل كامل
ويؤذي الفريق ولكن
يعمل تعمل جميع الفرق على امل ان يكون
هناك اشخاص على قيد الحياه غير مباليين
بهذه بهكذا امور بتسبب الطبيعه الجغرافيه
للدمار على اغلب مناطق شمال غرب سوريا
الارتداد الدمار كان كبير جدا
شكرا اليك استاذ احمد يازجي وايضا يعني
هذه الصرخه التي يجب ان تصل للعالم اجمع
لمساعده الشعب السوري في المناطق التي لم
تصلها المساعدات حتى اللحظه نحن نتحدث عن
مناطق باكمله لم تصلها مساعدات انسانيه
حتى اللحظه شكرا لك عضو مجلس اداره الدفاع
المدني السوري على هذه المداخله